[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على
حضراتكم حلقتنا النهارده هتكون عن ايران
ايران الحاضر الحاضر والغائب الحاضر في كل
القضايا المطروحه الان وخصوصا الحدث
الابرز وهو حرب غزه وضيفت اليوم هي
استاذتنا الدكتوره نفين مسعد استاذ النظم
السياسيه والمحلله السياسيه المعروفه مساء
الخير معال الدكتوره مساء النور يا استاذ
سيد ربنا يخلي حضرتك منورانا في هذا
البرنامج انا اللي متشرف بوجودي في
برنامجك يعني زائع الصيط الله يخلي حضرتك
الله يخليك انا عندي لما بيكون اي دوله
بنتكلم عليها عاده بتمشي الامور تحليل ا
بموضوعيه الى حد كبير يعني لما بتيجي
الامور عند ايران التعليقات بت تشع
التهابا بين التاييد وبين الادانه الاسباب
يطول شرحها لا تخفى على حضرتك وتحديدا
حضرتك انت بتتابعي من من الاكاديميين
والكتاب اللي اهتموا بايران من وقت مبكر
منذ اندلاع الثوره في سنه 79 يعني لكن
اسمح لي لان الاسئله كتيره ا هطرح اول
سؤال هيجي على ذهني واتمنى لو اجابه يعني
مختصره لان عندي عدد كبير من الاسئله في
تقدير حضرتك لو حبينا نلخص موقف ايران من
حرب غزه الى اي حد هي لعبت دور
في هجوم او حرب 7 اكتوبر كيف تدعمه ثم
هسالك هي مستفيده ولا متضرره منه هل هي
لعب الدور في تقديرك في هجوم 7 اكتوبر
بتصريحات مسؤوليها على اختلافهم لا هي لم
تلعب هذا الدور هي داعمه للمقاومه وبتتكلم
على مساله وحده الساحات ساحات المقاومه في
كل مكان فهي داعمه ومؤيده باشكال مختلفه
لكنها لم تكن طرفا في هذا الهجوم لا
بالتخطيط ولا بالتنفيذ واظن انه التصريحات
بهذا المعنى وردت منذ وقت
مبكر على السنه كل المسؤولين ابتداء من
المرشد مرورا برئيس الجمهوريه وانتهاء
بالخارجيه الى اخره فه بتنفي عن نفسها هذا
هذا الدور انما هي داعمه طبعا داعمه لفكره
المقاومه ولدور المقاومه في مواجهه
اسرائيل وهذا الدعم بيبدا بالعنصر الاهم
اللي هو المال والسلاح فضلا عن الدعم
الدبلوماسي والسياسي الى اخره مش كده برض
م دكتور طبعا هذا الدعم بمختلف اشكاله
والاسناد الايديولوجي كمان يعني الاسناد
الفكري
والايديولوجيات وغير المباشره شديده
الاهميه في ابقاء القضيه الفلسطينيه طوال
الوقت حاضره في الاذهان وموجوده ومثار وده
مهم جدا في تقدير حضرتك وبشكل موضوعي اذا
صنفنا مواقف دول مختلفه انا طبعا مش هسال
عن كل دول العالم هل ايران هي الدوله رقم
واحد من حيث الدعم ل حماس وفصائل المقاومه
في فلسطين ام تسبقها دول اخرى
ا يعني انا ما اقدرش اقول هي الدوله
الداعمه رقم واحد لكنها داعم رئيسي انا
علشان بحكم العمل يعني علشان اعطي رقم او
درجه لايران في مساله الدعم لابد ان يعني
اكون بينه على يعني بينه من اسهامات جميع
القوى الاخرى لكن في قوى اخرى
بتدعم المقاومه يعني تركيا على سبيل
المثال بتدعم المقاومه روسيا والصين لهم
مواقف داعمه للمقاومه باشكال مختلفه
فايران داعمه اساسيه خلينا بدل ما نقول
رقم 1د و 2 داعمه اساسيه لفكره المقاومه
هي مستفيده وفي الوقت نفسه
هي مفيده لهذه القضيه القوميه بامتياز هل
ايران وده طبعا سؤال هيبقى ديبيت بالل او
جدلي هل ايران دعمها للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
تحديدا وللمقاومة
حتى الجماعات الاخرى اسرائيل دايما في
المخيله هل هي توظف هذه الجماعات لتحقيق
مصالحها واولويات القوميه واللي هي بعيدا
عن مصالحها هي نفسها مستعده ان تستثمر في
هذه المقاومه من اجل تحقيق اهداف المقاومه
يعني فكره انه التوظيف يعني قصر دور ايران
على التوظيف او تحجيمه في مساله التوظيف
في الحقيقه انه بينزع عن هذه
القوى ارادتها و وكون انه هذه القوى لها
قضايا حقيقيه لو كان مثلا على المقاومه
العراقيه و لها قضيه مع الوجود الامريكي
بدون ايران وبوجود ايران المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لها قضيه في مواجهه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى اخره فهي داعمه بالتاكيد
وهذا الدعم بيتفق مع تصورها لفكره
المستضعفين في مواجهه المستكبرين وده
موجود من اول يوم وفي متن الدستور ايراني
والتزام ايران بدعم المستضعفين في كل في
كل مكان فهذا هو الاساس الايديولوجي
للثوره الايرانيه فكره نصره المستضعفين في
مواجهه المستكبرين نعم هي تدعمهم لكن هذه
الجماعات ايضا لها قضايا ولها مصالح وهي
لديها ما يدفعها الى الدفاع عن هذه
القضايا هل استفادت ايران ام تضررت من
هجوم 7 اكتوبر لان في وجهه نظر بتقول ان
ان هم استفادوا وفي وجهه نظر بتقول والله
فتحت عليهم ابوابا من التحديات ما كان
اغناها عن هذه يعني الاختبارات الصعبه
يعني في تقدير حضرتك هي استفادت مما حدث
بعد سب من 7 اكتوبر وما تلا حتى حتى الان
نعم هي استفادت ا اول فائده من وجهه نظري
هي يعني صرف النظر عن هذا الجدل العقيم في
الخلاف او الصراع المذهبي بين سنه وشيعه
ما حدش بقى يتكلم على سنه وشيعه ونحن
راينا ارتفاع سهم الحوثيين وهم يقومون ب
ما يقومون به في في البحر الاحمر وفي
البحر بشكل بشكل عام فتصور انه اسقاط هذا
الجدل العقيم والصراع السني الشيعي ده
اتصور انه انتهى دي دي نقطه اولى استفادت
اقليميا ايران يعني طوال الوقت تركيا كانت
بتقدم نفسها باعتبارها هي الفاعل الرئيس
وده بسبب بقى تواصلها مع الاغلبيه الساحقه
من شعوب هذه المنطقه على المستوى الديني
والمذهبي يعني ا تركيا دورها محدود في هذه
المعركه يعني دورها محدود اه طبعا في
تصعيد في الخطاب الاعلامي واشياء من هذا
القبيل ومحاوله لعب دور وساطه لكن ايران
حاضره طوال الوقت ولذلك نجد انه التهديدات
الامريكيه والتهديدات الاوروبيه دائما
بتتجه لايران ليس لتركيا لانه ايران يعني
هي الداعم زي ما احنا قلنا وهذا الدعم
مؤسس على ايديولوجيه ثلاثه انه اتضاح قوه
ايران بهذا
المعسكر الذي تنتمي اليه هو معسكر
المقاومه وفكره وحده الساحات لابد ان يكون
حاضرا على اي طاوله مفاوضات تجلس عليها
ايران اتضحت يعني طبعا هي قوه واضحه من
الاول هي القوه واضحه من البدايه لكن زادت
تاكدت تعمقت وبالتالي تالي طوال الوقت نجد
التحذيرات من عدم توسيع نطاق الحرب يعني
من الولايات المتحده عدم توسيع نطاق الحرب
وعدم دخول ايران فيها او الاطراف المختلفه
امتداد طبيعي لكل فصائل المقاومه اللي احد
اطرافها الان مشتبك مع اسرائيل او احد
طرفيها كمان يعني ف يعني اللي عايزه اقوله
انه انه هذه اوراق اوراق للضغط يعني هذه
كلها اوراق للضغط لصالح ايران لصالح ايران
طبعا حب الله يجي لي اللي عاوز يتكلم حماس
والجهاد ممكن يجي لي اللي عاوز يتكلم
الحشد الشعبي ممكن يجي لي حوثي الهدف او
يعني الفايده الرابعه صرف الانظار عن
القضايا عن القضايا الداخليه واحيانا في
بعض الدول بس مش في الحاله الايرانيه يعني
بتفتل مشاكل خارجيه لصرف ودي استراتيجيه
معروفه لصرف الانتباه عن
القضايا الداخليه قضايا الفساد ولسه كان
عندهم قضيه كبيره متعلقه بفساد الشاي يعني
في تلاعب في صفقه شاي واشياء من
هذا اه يعني هو تم
التعاقد على صفقه شاي بمواصفات معينه ولكن
تم التراجع عنها ف حكومه رئيسي او اداره
رئيسي بتلقي التهمه على حكومه او اداره
روحاني مغشوش يعني باسع يعني يعني مش
بالضبط مغشوش ولكن يعني يعني اقل من
المواصفات التي تم الاتفاق عليها مساله
المصاعب الاقتصاديه الداخليه و كل ده ف
وبالاضافه الى
يعني المشاكل الاجتماعيه عموما اللي
بتعيشها ايران فصرف النظر عنها الى الخارج
طيب الى الداخل بقى احنا احنا بنتكلم على
مساله المصاعب بقى او المشاكل التي واجهه
ايران
نتيجه اكتب هجوم 7 اكتوبر وموقف اول شيء
انه بعض ارتدادات هذا الهجوم بتدخل الى
الداخل بترد الى الداخل يعني تفجير كرمان
اللي اعلن تنظيم داعش مسؤوليته عنه
التفجير في منتهى الضخامه اه وكان بمناسبه
يعني احياء ذكرى قاسم سليماني قائد فيلق
القدس الح في ا يناير 2020 في 3 يناير
2020 هذا الحدث سواء داعش اللي قامت بهيه
منطقا نفسها سواء اسرائيل ونسقت مع داش مع
داعش ايا كان انما هذا حدث في في في داخل
في داخل ايران ارتدادات الحدث طالت ايران
زي مطاله دول اخرى دي نقطه اولى النقطه
الثانيه يعني الخساره الثانيه هي خساره لم
تحدث ولكن ا ممكن تحدث فكره انه طوال
الوقت نحن بنتكلم على ضبط الصراع وانه عدم
تجاوز المعركه نطاق فلسطين وهذا مستحيل
يعني وهذا مستحيل وبنفترق الرشاده في جميع
الفاعلين في الميدان وهذا ليس يعني مضمونا
اولا لان بعض الفاعلين ليسوا راشدين
بالفعل يعني احنا شايفين رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي ماضم في طريقه ولا شيء بيوقفوا
ابدا عن يتمنى توسيع نطاق الصراع لانه
مستفيد هو مستفيد باستمراره في موقعه وعدم
محاكمته اشياء من هذا القبيل فمقدرش اقول
انه الشخص رشيد بالاضافه الى انه بعض
تطورات المعارك قد تؤدي الى افلات الزمام
وقد تجعل من الصعب السيطره على الموقف
يعني مثلا تطور الامر في يعني فيما يتعلق
بتهديد الملاحه البحريه او ا طرار
الولايات المتحده انها ترد بعنف في
داخل العراق ويمكن نتكلم عليه بعد كده ف
اشياء من هذا القبيل يمكن ان تلهب هي
موجوده على الحافه ان في اي لحظه ممكن
تتطور الاحداث وتخرج عن السيطره وبالتالي
اللي تجد نفسها متورطه في حرب يعني مع
الولايات المت ضبط ضبط الصراع طوال الوقت
وخصوصا كل ما طال امد الصراع كل ما اصبحت
عمليه الضبط متعذر يعني هو في سؤالين يا
معالي الدكتوره بمناسبه النقطه الاخيره
حضرتك قلت ان هي مستفيده نعم واحد انين 3
لكن واحد انين وثلاثه دي خلاصتها ان ده
ازدادت قوه وشعبيه ايران على المستوى
العربي خارجيا المستوى الاقليمي والاسلامي
اه خارجيا وعلى المستوى الداخلي جزء من
الاستفاده انها صرفت الكثير من الايراني
عن مشاكلهم الداخليه بالتحدي الخارجي وهي
متضرره لانه طبعا على المستوى الداخلي برض
بتزيد الشكوى شويه من استنزاف الموارد
الاقتصاديه من اجل قضايا ليست من اولويات
بعض الايرانيين اللي زي اي شعب عاوز ياكل
ويشرب ويتعالج ا بتعمق الخلاف مع الغرب
برض وهم بيقولوا ان اولويتنا هو التصالح
مع الغرب وبتقولي كمان حضرتك ان في تحدي
اخر وهو ان هم بيقترب اكثر واكثر من
احتمال المواجهه عندي سؤالين السؤال
الاولاني هو حكايه اقتراب المواجهه دي انا
اسمعها من سنه 79
يعني
صحيح وطول الوقت بتيجي ازمات والازمات
بتقترب قوي الى درجه تشعري انه المدافع
سوف تنطلق في اللحظه
التاليه المدافع لا تنطلق ابدا حتى مش بس
لما هم اغتالوا قاسم سليماني وقاسم
سليماني هو من هو ولكن ده لم تنطلق حتى ل
ايران اسقطت طائره يعني امريكيه
وامريكا القوه العظمى في العالم ف يعني
بدنا يعني نشك في فكره انه الحرب من كتر
خوف كل الاطراف منها انها ممكن تنطلق ابدا
يعني طيب حضرتك محق تماما في هذا التحليل
لكن هقول انه الوضع اللي احنا موجودين فيه
ما يشبه وضع اغتيال قاسم سليماني ا ليه
لانه احنا
قدام معركه متعدده الجب جبهات وكل جبهه من
هذه الجبهات جايز بتنسق او اكيد بتنسق مع
غيرها من الجبهات لكن كمان هذا التنسيق
ليس تاما او ليس كاملا وبالتالي فكره ضبط
الصراع بتبقى اصعب في حاله قاسم سليماني
احنا عندنا اعتداء قرب مطار بغداد على
قاسم سليماني هو وابو مهدي المهندس وقات
لهم الى اخره
فالمستهلك الاثنين مع بعض ما كانش في
فلسطين ما كانش في لبنان الى اخره ما كانش
في اليمن ما كانش اصلا الاص تطورت اه ف
ففي هذه الحاله احنا اذاء يعني صراع محدود
احنا هنا اذاء صراع مفتوح على كل
المستويات وكل يوم والثاني بنشاه مزيد من
التصعيد في هذا الصراع
نشوف القيادات المغتال مستوى القيادات
التي تم اغتيالها سواء على ا يعني على
الصعيد العراقي او على الصعيد اللبناني او
طبعا على الصعيد الفلسطيني احنا بنتكلم
على صف اول ف يعني ف تعدد الجبهات
واستهداف عناصر رئيسيه او صف اول في هذه
الجبهات كافه ا ده ممكن يؤدي الى تدحرج
كره الثلج او بقى كره ال كره النار محلله
سياسيه لا
تستبعده لع فعلا حرب اقليميه وتكون ايران
طرف رئيسي فيها
اا اه اه يعني انا لو لو لو كنت محلله
سياسيه واستبعدت هذا الاحتمال ففي الحقيقه
انا بحرم نفسي من فرصه انه ادخل متغيرات
مختلفه في عمليه التحليل حتى هذا الامر
كان واردا في 2006 على سبيل المثال لما
اسرائيل اعتدت على على لبنان كنا بنشوف
انه ممكن الصراع يتوسع وممكن ايران تدخل
في في اللعبه وكذا لكن
تم احتواء الصراع فطوال الوقت هذا الامر
قائم لكن مع تعدد الجبهات
بيكون ا يعني انا انا بستاذن حضرتك يعني
وصحح يعني انا ليه انا يعني بجد طبعا كل
شيء وارد والا لو مش كل شيء وارد يعني
تبقى الناس كلها واثقه من النتائج ده ضد
طبيعه الاشياء ولكن احنا حتى عندنا على
الجبهات الاخرى حاله حاله الخوف مخليه
انضباط النفس ا تمام يعني احنا بنشوف
الاستفزاز مثلا بين اطراف متعدده على
الساحه الاوكرانيه مافيش اكتر من كده ان
الولايات المتحده متورطه في قتل جنود روس
بالسلاح الامريكي ومستشارين واستخبارات
ومع ذلك في حاله انضباط
يعني الصين عمليه استفزاز وسفن بتزحف
بالاكتاف يعني اذا جاز التعبير وحاله
انضباط كذلك ايران حاله انضباط هائله يعني
بين كل الاطراف ان كل واحد
بيعاير الحجم الليمو زم يتوقف عنده في
نقطتين النقطه الاولى انه في اصبح عمليه
انزياح لما كان يسمى بقواعد الاشتباك ان
اطوال الوقت بيقولوا انتوا كده تخطيت
قواعد الاشتباك ولما تتخطى قواعد الاشتباك
ما تبقاش بقى هذه المساله من الانضباط دي
نقطه قصدك ان قواعد الاشتباك بتح تتزحزح
تغغير فدي نقطه النقطه الثانيه انا يعني
هفكر حضرتك بما يحدث في
اوكرانيا هل من الوارد انه احنا في القرن
ال
21 نفكر في انه احتمال تنشب حرب نوويه الم
يكن
هذا الاحتمال جنونيا يعني هذا الاحتمال
كان جنوني فاحنا بقى مش بنتكلم على ايران
في مواجهه اسرائيل لا ده احنا بنتكلم بقى
على حرب نوويه لا تبقي ولا تدرر ف
وابتدينا نتكلم عن على استخدام محدود او
منضبط للسلاح النووي الايه الروسي فما لا
يعقل ارض المعركه بجعله يعقل يعني لو
تصورنا انه تم الاجها الاطباق على روسيا
من كافه من كافه
الجهات تم المبالغه في استفزازها الى درجه
لم يعد قدامها خيار الا ع وعلى اعدائي
تعمل ايه ف يعني يعني من منظور المقارنه
هذا الاحتمال وارد ماه واش مرجح لكنه و
فكره اندلاع حرب اقليميه تكون ايران طرف
رئيسي فيه طبعا في مواجهه الولايات
المتحده اصلا اصلا يعني اجتياح روسيا
لاوكرانيا لم يكن واردا اجتياح العراق
للكويت او استلاء على الكويت لم يكون
واردا فبعض التحليلات غير الرشيده ا يعني
مطلوبه الحرب العالميه الاولى لم تكن
وارده طيب عاوز اسال حضرتك سؤالين اخرين
قبل ان ننقل الى يعني اطراف اخرى انا عندي
سؤال سالته لحضرتك لما شرفتيني هنا يمكن
في 2020 بس محتاج ان انا اطرحه ثاني
واستاذن لو ممكن نوجز لاصدقائنا اللي ما
يعرفوش كتير عن ايران اي لو اعدت السؤال
عليك ماذا تريد ايران خصوصا في ظل
المتغيرات التاليه ماذا تريد ايران ايران
تريد ان تثبت نفسها كقوه اقليميه كبيره
بكل معنى الكلمه وهي تفعل ذلك سياساتها من
خلق شبكه من التحالفات مع اطراف اقليميه
وايضا دوليه روسيا الصين تدخل البريكس الى
اخره ا تبقى حاضره في المفاوضات بشان
سوريا موجوده في العراق موجوده في اليمن
الى اخره فهي تريد ان تكون قوه اقليميه
بهذه الافعال حتى بالاقوال لما يجي ا احد
المسؤولين الايرانيين يقول احنا
لدينا السيطره على القرار في اربع في اربع
عواصم عربيه او
قبل يعني قليل يعني يمكن في في غضون هذه
الحرب قيل انه لا شيء تخذ في فلسطين بدون
استشاره ايران او او يعني ايران تكون لها
راي فيه فايران تريد ان تثبت نفسها قوه
اقليميه وعندما تكون قوه اقليميه كبيره
فهذا معناه انه عند اي ترتيب للاوضاع في
المنطقه لابد ان تكون حاضره ان تكون جالسه
على
الطاوله وعاده القوه الكبرى القوه الدوليه
الكبيره يعني عندما تتعامل مع مناطق
العالم المختلفه تتوجه الى القوه
الاقليميه البارزه القوه الاقليميه
البارزه تراهن عليها تسعى الى عقد تحالفات
معها الى اخره ده رقم واحد انا هسالك عن
رقم اثنين بس مش هي قوه اقليميه يعني يعني
تقصد ان هي تبقى قوه اقليميه بالغه النفو
يعني لا لا يعني قوه اقليميه يعني زي ما
احنا كنا بنتكلم على الحرب قلنا انها ها
زادت من قوتها وزادت من نفوذها
و وكون انه ما بيبقاش في تصعيد زي ما
حضرتك بتقول فده لاسباب مختلفه اهمها
الدور الايراني انا فاهم ان اللي حضرتك
بتقوليه ده في اطار ان في دول كبرى زي
الولايات المتحده او دول في المنطقه عاوزه
اصلا تحجم من نفوذها فيتفق من فيتفق في
هذا السياق ان هي عاوزه تمارس دور اقليمي
كبير لان هي المفروض لو ما فيش كل
التحديات ديت ومافيش كل الخلافات دي مع
هذه الدول هي الطبيعي ان هي قوه اقليميه
كبيره زائد انه في في في ملفات ثانيه من
كتر ما يعني الحرب شغلتنا احنا مش ملتفتين
ليها مساله الملف النووي الايراني ده زائد
ايه بقى يعني ده الهدف الاولاني احنا بقول
ماذا تري تبقى قوه اقليميه كبيره دلوقتي
الملف النووي الايراني يعني لو كان ترامب
وقت ما انسحب من من الاتفاق النوي في 2018
يدرك انه ايران سوف تقوم بتخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه 60% اظن انه ما كانش عمل
كده يعني دلوقتي ايران يعني ماشيه في
عمليه التخصيب هذه والمجتمع الدولي يعني
كمت كميات كبيره منه اه ر راكمت كميات
كبيره منه ف ده ايضا ده ايضا عنصر من
عناصر القوه يعني يعني عنصر من عناصر
بالتاكيد لما تجلس على الطاوله وهي دوله
على عتبه نوويه على العتبه النوويه فده
يديها اهم ماذا تريد ايران تريد ان تكون
حاضره وموجوده
ومؤثره اقليميا وبالتالي دوليا عظيم ايه
تاني
ا هي تسعى طبعا تسعى غير انها تحققه تسعى
ومعها مجموعه من دول العالم المختلفه الى
نظام دولي اكثر عداله مع الروس وم الصينين
مع الروس مع الصينيين مع ا العديد مع
تركيا مع الكثير من الدول مع الدول
العربيه الى ان يكون هناك
تعديل ل صيغه الامم المتحده وطريقه صنع
القرار واتخاذ القرار في داخل مجلس الامن
تنجح او ماتنجحش لا طبعا ده ده يعني اكبر
من قدره ايران لكنه مرتبط بديناميات
التفاعل على مستوى النظام الدولي ككل لكن
هذا احد الاهداف ان تكون مرئيه اكثر على
مستوى النظام الدولي مش بس بقى على
المستوى الاقليمي ودول هدفين كبار عظيم
جدا انا قلت سؤالين معلش نخليهم يفاضل لنا
سؤالين السؤال الثاني بما ان انت اكلمت
على السلاح النوي قبل ما اسال حضرتك
السؤال الاخير هل حضرتك تعتقدي ان ايران
جاده في ان هي لا ترغب في امتلاك سلاح
نووي ام ان هذا كلامه في الهواء انا رايي
انه ايران ترغب في امتلاك سلاح نووي رغم
كل الفتاوى ور رغم كل رغم كل الفتاوى يعني
ا ايران دفعت ثمنا غاليا جدا جدا من اجل
هذا هذا الموضوع
ا وعرضت عليها يعني عروض مختلفه
ا من اجل ان تصرف نظر عن تطوير
برنامجها النووي ووقف ابحاثها واشياء من
هذا
القبيل وخلينا نقول انه من حق ايران ان
تطالب بان تكون دوله نوويه طالما انه
اسرائيل دوله نوويه وباكستان والهند فنحن
في عالم به دول نوويه قوه اقليميه كبيره
نوويه يعني لا يمكن ان ادافع عن يعني
حرمان ايران من السلاح النووي طول ما
اسرائيل عندها سلاح نووي واسرائيل هي
الخسم الاساسي لايران نتطلع الى اخلاء
الشرق الاوسط من السلاح النو نتطلع يا رب
لكن طالما انه لم يتحقق هذا ف ايران من
حقها ان تتطلع الى امتلاك السلاح النوسي
السؤال الاخير يا معالي الدكتوره هو
الحقيقه سؤال بيردني على مدار سنوات وبشكل
متكرر من مجموعه تسال السؤال التالي انت
مصدق ان ايران واسرائيل اعداء هؤلاء محبان
يتشاركان سقفا واحدا يعني مش عاوز اقول
التعبير اللي بيقولوه في قناعه ان ايران
واسرائيل ليسوا عدوين وانه دي مجرد ا كده
يعني وهم في الحق ينسخوا كل شيء من خلف
الكواليس السؤال متكرر فانا بطرحه على
حضرتك ا هو طبعا في المقوله الشهيره في
السياسه ا انه في السياسه لا يوجد اعداء
دائمون ولا اصدقاء دائمون لكن كمان في
منطق للامور يعني يكون انه ايران في وقت
من الاوقات ا مثلا تستورد سلاح من اه من
اسرائيل ده كانت في ح او بساطه اسرائيليه
طبعا مش اسرائيل بواسطه اسرائيليه لانه
كانت في ظرف دفاع عن النفس كانت في حرب
الثمان سنوات دي حادثه كون انه ايران
بتنسق مع بعض جماعات الاسلام المتشدده زي
داعش وغير داعش واشياء من هذا القبيل لانه
ممكن تكون لها مصلحه حتى داعش بعت بعت نفط
ل تركيه فاقصد ان احنا يجب ان ان نميز بين
التوجه التكتيكي والتوجه الاستراتيجي
الاستراتيجيا ايران مش ممكن تكون حليف
لاسرائيل ولا يمكن ان تكون صديقه لاسرائيل
احنا عندنا طرحين مختلفين للشرق الاوسط
لنظام الشرق الاوسط المتصور يعني
تصور اسرائيلي وغربي طبعا تصور اسرائيلي
غربي امريكي الى اخره وتصور ايراني ومعها
كل المحور الذي تمثله طبعا في تصور ثاني
تركي يعني تصور تركي بس طالما احنا بنتكلم
على هذين النموذجين فالاثنين
يعني متعاكسين يعني لو تشوف حضرتك
هذا الاصرار الاسرائيلي الشديد على عدم
العوده الى طاوله المفاوضات فيما يتعلق
بالاتفاق النووي حتى تحرمها اي فرصه من
تطوير الاصح النوويه يعني يعني ودي من
الاشياء الغريبه اللي الاداره الامريكيه
بتواجه فيها الضغط الاسرائيلي يعني بتقف
فيها في وجه الضغط الاسرائيلي يعني
لا الاداره الحاليه هي رغم كل يعني
علاقتها الجيده او الممتازه او التوحد مع
اسرائيل لا ذهبت الى الى التفاوض الى الى
ان توقف يعني ف اللي عايزه اقوله لا في في
طرح مختلف تماما طرح الامريكي الاسرائيلي
بشرق اوسط تهيمن عليه اسرائيل وتنشر
القرايه او كوكيل على الولايات المتحده
والطرح الايراني انه هذه المنطقه لهذه
الدول وهذه الدول انا منها وانا هكون يعني
وبالتالي هي طوال الوقت بتطرح ايران طوال
الوقت بتطرح مثلا مبادرات يعني مبادره
هورمز انه السلام في منطقه الخليج ويتم
ازاي عمل هذا هذا السلام طبعا ده كان في
وقت حسن روحاني وقبل كده طوال الوقت بتطرح
مبادرات هدفها انه تكون هي المايسترو في
عمليه ضبط ايقاع هذا النظام الشرق اوسطي
فانا من وجهه نظري مع يعني مع مع احترامي
لكل يعني انصار نظريه المؤامره ا لا ا
يعني ايران واسرائيل قد تتقاطع اهدافه ما
في ظرف من الظروف لكن هما ليس حليفان ولا
يمكن او ليس حليفين ولا يمكن ان يكون لما
تيجي ايران والولايات المتحده وهذا نفس
الوضع ا تحارب داعش في العراق والولايات
المتحده تحارب داعش في العراق هم الاثنين
تلقت مصالحهم او يحاربوا هم الاثنين
القاعده في افغانستان هم الاثنين تلقت
مصالحهم انما مش معنى كده انه ايران حريفه
للولايات المتحده فهو ده اللي اقصد ان
احنا نميز ما بين الهدف الاستراتيجي او
الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه وبين الهدف التكتيكي
او الرؤيه قصيره المدى يمكن ده يدي فعلا
اجابه للاستفسارات اللي في ادهان كثير من
اصدقائنا ل انه او من يعني مقتنعين يتبنوا
وجهه النظر دي هو الخلط ما بين ان انا
تكون عدو ويؤطر للتعامل معاك وده بيحصل في
كل زمان وفي كل مكان وحضرتك لما بتشير الى
الاسلحه الامريكيه اللي كانت عن طريق
اسرائيل او الاسلحه اللي جت يعني من
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل اللي هي سميت
بايران ايران جيت فايران جيت دي ان ايران
كانت في حاجه الى سلاح الى سلاح والولايات
المتحده كانت محتاجه تمول صوار الكونترا
وكانت محتاجه كمان اظن كان وقتها ازمه هي
كانت محتاجاها يعني كان لها احتياجات من
ايران كانت محتاجه يعني محتاجه شيء كمان
من ايران غير الفلوس فده ممكن يتم يعني
انا محتاج وانت محتاج رغم ان احنا الاثنين
اعداء وده بيحصل فيه ا يعني يعني قضايا
متعدده لكن هذا لا يعني اننا اصدقاء زي ما
بتقول حرك ولا يمكن ان يكونوا اصد
الولايات المتحده
وال وطلبان في في افغانستان يعني يعني هل
كان احد يتصور ان هم الاثنين اللي تحاربه
والولايات المتحده دخلت افغانستان من اجل
اسقاط حكم طلبان في النهايه تتفاوض مع
وتخرج الضروره اقتضت المصلحه اقتضت انما
مش معنى كده انه الولايات المتحده حليفه
للحكم الافغان
الحالي انا اكثر من شكر معالي الدكتوره
احنا اتكلمنا على جانب سريع من ايران ولكن
الحديث عن ايران دائما مطروح في ملفات
اخرى وانا حابب اطرح مع حضرتك ملفات اخرى
تتعلق تحديدا بالعراق وسوريا وقد ايه حرب
غزه يمكن ان تاخذهم الى تحديات ما كانوا
يعني مستعدين للدخول فيها لولا هذه الحرب
بس استاذنك ده يكون في حلقات اخرى باذن
الله يسعدني يا استاذ سيد ربنا يخليك
ويسعدك شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم مع
الدكتوره نيفين مسعد في حلقات اخرى باذن
الله